[Music]
so many stars in Hollywood continue to
send love and support to Demi Lovato
during this difficult time including
Lady gaga she tweeted quote we all wish
you self compassion and inner peace you
know Gaga also battled addiction she is
just one of the stars who has found
sobriety while remaining in the
spotlight I can't imagine what Demi is
going through right now even though I
know what it's like to have the whole
world talking about you and your most
vulnerable state
Demi's friend kelly osbourne has also
struggled with drugs and alcohol and
witnessed her father as he wrestled with
his own substance abuse issues
kelly told the british talk show loose
women that staying clean can be a
lifelong challenge relapse is one of the
hardest things we face people need to
know rehab doesn't fix you it just helps
you to get yourself on the right track
you're never fixed you spend your whole
entire life doing everything you can to
never pick up and use again
lady gaga knows what demi is feeling
right now because she wants abused
marijuana to deal with the pain from a
hip injury I have been addicted to it
and it's ultimately related to anxiety
coping and it's a form of
self-medication and I was smoking up to
15 to 20 marijuana cigarettes a day
Wendy Williams kept her drug demons
hidden I lost over a decade of my life
being hooked on cocaine I was a
functioning addict now I report to work
on time
Fergie toed Oprah she became hooked
before becoming a household name I
started going out and taking ecstasy
you know from ecstasy I went to crystal
meth and slowly your life starts to
spiral down it almost killed you right
90 pounds 90 pounds at one point some of
Hollywood's biggest stars have had their
lives turned upside down from substance
abuse Nicole Richie was busted for DUI
as well as for heroin possession
Angelina Jolie admitted to using cocaine
and heroin in her younger days and Drew
Barrymore struggles with drugs and
alcohol led to rehab when she was just
13 I feel that I have a lot to live for
through being sober and I feel like I've
been given so many gifts that right now
I have no desire to throw them away
[Music]